but uh do you have any upcoming plans or
any projects that you excited actually
I'm becoming a game character too I mean
game characters no what aren't you doing
Jesus you're doing everything well under
N I cannot talk about details yet but uh
IID up beat upap that's my favorite
genre always playing Beat yes and I'm
going to be beating my character and I
was like I want this going to be a DLC
character so like I'm going to be I have
to be stronger right than the main
characters right and I want to have a
unique weapon and I thought about I want
to fight with bread okay so with bread
bread yes well like a big bagette I want
to have bread as Katana style and also I
want croan for shuriken style like you
have to like long range attack right and
then for middle age I want to have toast
and like kind of do the
circleing
attack why what wait hold on why why the
Brad yeah why how did you get to Brad
the one fighter that instant defeat me
maybe like a Seda uniform kind of
costume and like oh SED uniform bread
toast and can I how did you make that
connection because the [__] [__] like
putting the bread in the toast in the
mouth thing and also I play like Akiba
strip this is like akba stripping game
and you can fight with a bread actually
baget you can attack somebody with
bagette wa wait can we come back five
second what is the akba stripping game
yeah a game called AA strip what the
[__] is that and you stripped uh you
can't strip normal people but there are
vampires and vampires are susceptible to
like you know sunlight right weak
against sunlight so you have to strip
them to reveal their skin and then they
get by the sunlight yeah wa so you're
trying to kill the vampire by ripping
off the CL yeah but they're all hot
chicks yeah some of boys some of boys
yeah okay so some of boys some of boys
you know we don't judge it's is it a
good game it is I do enjoy the ACT I
even play the sequel okay damn is one of
those like just dumb fun games you know
like you don't take it all that
seriously it's like Saints Row you know
like you don't take that [__]
seriously it sounds fun yes it is I got
to check it
out no you're not yeah you're definitely
going to check it out going to check it
out check it out you play on Twitch
right can I play it on Twitch is it that
bad yes you can you can I okay that's
fine then yeah if I can play if I can
play it on Twitch it's not that bad
right Conor's Conor's idea of checking
it out is just going on Google and just
looking at being like all right I
checked it out you can PR a s on on
Twitch so what's wait what's that oh
always boobs and oh sometimes you know
it's jiggle physics the game uh Dead or
Alive no more than Dead or Alive more
than Dead or Alive it makes Dead or
Alive look tame it's it there was an
anime back in like what
201 I think you was big on Pachinko
you've definitely seen this
before one no no you're going have to
narrow down the one where they fight
with the butts on the platform that's no
yeah K and they had Pinko and I did the
Pachinko promotion at Nik Niko
broadcasting because they needed girls
with big
boobs is that how they pitch it to you
they're like Kaho we're looking for
someone with big mobs we think you're a
great fit his money fair enough I mean
hey Fair yeah as you said your um do you
get some of those stuff like freelance
or is that all man like agencies you're
doing no freance and I have a website
and
they that's awesome I was going to say I
was like Dam after all the agency talk
we
talk a't going to go by the way I'm
still part of an agency I just hire ERS
and like it's not even like their main
job more side job so I can just pay not
so much and they can just skim through
some emails and then oh yeah you're
doing the smart yeah and they can help
me at the booth like at conventions only
when I need them yeah oh [__] yeah
awesome what's like the weirdest request
like a TV show or like some client has
asked you to take part of in in an event
has there any been like a weird request
or anything like that I mean for the SAG
one we put like a walking the
that's like a walking oh the uh the the
thing that counts stamps what are they
called again spe pedometer pedometer
yeah so we put it here or I forgot which
part about around the booths and we were
just
jiggle and check the count that is the
most Japanese thing I've heard for what
purpose oh yeah I forgot maybe you win
you win something look the these agency
guys were like listen K we need to
figure out your jiggle per minute uh
show we got to see who's number one yeah
maybe if you get the count right then
you get the count then you get something
in the audience I don't know I totally
forgotten they like is this trying to
like be like some kind of thing being
like wow look how much your boobs jiggle
yeah cuz that's s s is all about the
jiggle
physics so it's kind of Genius but also
lowkey or high key creepy as hell it has
nothing to do with the
Pinko I was like this is nothing to do
with pinko but this is this sounds like
a decision made in a boardroom with a bu
of bus with their dicks in their so
what's purpose of doing this we just
want to see some tits BS that's all at
least from my experience working with
Japanese companies uh they love to add
things in last minute true they love
adding things on like little things
constantly they you'll get that and
they'll be like we want to do this this
you're like okay why didn't we like
write this down and agree on it yeah
yeah but because I have done those
things in the past I have to be really
careful now that
uh let's make sure that I have
rebranding and yeah like I don't do some
things anymore and try make sure that
they know that yeah like respect the
boundaries now that your position has
changed right yeah for sure are most uh
clients like chill with that those
boundaries or some of them like w we
don't do you want to do this crazy thing
or yeah sometime I just have we just
have to part ways obviously sometime
they listen or they pretend to listen
but turns out they're not listening at
all so yeah jeez there are those people
so you really have to be careful well I
think you've been pretty successful with
your image change especially since the
last time you came on just seeing the
amount of different projects and seeing
the different uh more diverse yeah see
the diverse amount of things you've been
involved in it's very you've definitely
played it smart as well in the fact that
you've uh not only like managed to kind
of Branch yourself out into so many
different like positions but you've done
it in a way where it's like a slow
transition so it seems way more natural
than like just suddenly being like yes
so I used to do JV and uh now I'm in a
video game it's like you know it's like
it's it's not like that you know it's
like you just kind of slowly transition
people to be like oh yeah of course K's
in a game now that makes sense you know
so yeah you've you've you've played it
smart I think thank you yeah just try to
do gradually because I still like I'm
not going to hide the fact I did that
but the same time I'm not going to keep
pitching the past like that's kind of
unol I did this in the past you're not
going to keep waving the flag right yeah
totally is there anything else you want
to do in the future that you already
seem to be doing what what haven't you
done yet is there like a dream you want
to get know there so many different
things I want to yeah I want to be more
involved in the project from the
beginning or more not just be in it but
not just join a creative position I do
actually enjoy that yeah yeah and I have
just they doing work all the time and
you know what whenever like people try
to get me into like a sex conversation
now I'm like like hey I'm not having it
I don't want it
anymore yeah I'm not interested in
having sex but I still eat HTI and watch
handai but it's like oh 2D staff for me
I need that 3D [__] dog like it's the co
help like hey I don't want to you know
exchange saliva or like body fluid it
doesn't feel safe like and because I
don't go out that much like my immune
system is so L like I I guess I want to
catch something even from like handh
holding okay first yeah you go to Anime
conventions they are the most disease
ridden places in the world yeah so if
you the one that's one that's one step
away from
get sick if you can survive an Anime Con
I think you can survive good outside
it's like you don't understand if we
kiss I will
die I have zero immune system when I was
in the industry I guess like I have to
kind of enjoy the War I think I was no
know doing the Persona and enjoyed all
the compliment of my body and like I
want to I don't know I want to do like
sensor syns you yeah and then of course
I would smile all the time but now I
feel like yeah thank for no thanks you
say that to your face H they do
sometimes even what wait at conventions
a conv well at adult convention those
are more obvious got obviously there was
a Gua even in Las Vegas like at adult
convention said like oh can I uh pay you
and play with your uh boobs later on and
old guy old old guy and I'll pay you
good and like oh least strange
American that's average Las Vegas
resident
completely legal like even in this
country so like okay like like okay I
just don't understand first of all the
balls to just say that to someone's face
but like two just think like what was he
expecting for you to be like well it
depends on the amount of money you're
going to give me like yeah like [__]
Jesus that kind I mean I'm sure there
are like you know some women who go who
guest at those adult conventions who you
know maybe they'll say yes to that right
but like you can't just [__] go
around yeah just respect the B
also there's a less like direct way to
say it right as well and from the sounds
of it he was way too direct with get to
the point yeah yeah I don't know I think
either way wherever he's working at he
not there is there is no way to say's no
heing with uh you know class yeah of
course of course oh jeez the fact that
he's just asking that [__] to begin with
you know but I hope anime fans are
respectful they are very they would do
like H hands
okay I
love do you think that's out of respect
I believe it's out of respect you know
that is that is the one thing I hope
that never dies in Anime conventions
havan that [__] is always hilarious Le I
just like make a heart with them at Le
the tto do you do like this thing they
do that sometimes they do that yeah your
friend is owning like that yeah that's
my favorite yeah at least fans are like
adorably awkward you know yeah that's
the thing yes yes yes yeah don't change
don't change your yeah don't change
enemy fans stay already keep the h a
hand I like the h a hand H hand's fun oh
have you noticed that last time you guys
are all wearing evaran and I was just
wearing a I I love your dress ever and
all the Rings too you always find I'm so
jealous
l oh [__] that's
sick amaz where' did you get the dress
oh this is from well a company called
candy stripper in Japan they're a legit
clothing company it's just there's so
many English word you can find in Japan
that sounds really weird okay I'm
surprised you even remember the fact cuz
like when you when you were saying like
oh yeah you you guys were all wearing
Ava shirs last time I'm like how do you
remember that I didn't remember I was
like I feel kind of left out no I'm just
wearing mother freaking m i felt so your
memory is crazy you always say stuff to
me and I'm like I forgot that 10 minutes
after it happened I I don't remember
even like what every gar and cter
underwear too that's not going to be
shown
I who are you matching that the full set
the full commitment like too much
information oh my God just needed uh
true AA fan right here